друзі Всіх вітаю це один із трьох штабів
госпітальєрів найбільшої системи
парамедиків у Яни Зінкевич безумовною
народної героїні в її команді працює
сьогодні більше 500 пара медиків На жаль
серед них Під час цієї великої війни є
загиблі є ті хто залишається в полоні є
ті хто звільнені з полону є поранені але
ці хлопці і дівчата пара медики щодня
рятують людей Зараз у мене працює понад
50 550 парамедиків плюс до всього 70
чоловік який обслуговують е-е Наші всі
бази для того щоб люди мали по
харчуватися лягти на свіжу постіль і
змогли отримати все що необхідно для
відпочинку між ротаціями відповідно всі
ці групи рятуються між собою ми
закриваємо дуже велику ділянку фронту і
Хочу наголосити що дуже важливий факт
в нас виходить від початку червоного
ставці ми були до неї готові аптечки Так
Мед все что для тактичної медицини
скільки важить у рюкзак парамедика І що
ви туди кладете порядка 10 до 10 кг
позиции
це підготовка була дуже важливою
і організованою
і коштів для того щоб так як ми не
отримуємо державної допомоги стільки ми
змогли і закупити більше броніків більше
касок тому що я розуміла що це буде
раптово і ближче до того навіть 24 числа
і коли один депутат зі слуг народу
ходив з якоїсь проституткою на поверсі а
я о 12:00 ночі з Софією фединеною нашою
пакували рюкзаки і я знала що цю ніч це
станеться І що це відбудеться і тому я
чекала коли прокинулася я зараз
зрозуміла що це є в нас в машині вже
було все запаковано і ми виїхали одразу
на центр нашого збору батальйону У нас є
був Михайлівський собор і був Павлоград
відповідно дві точки кому куди ближче і
всі люди почали збиратися і в мене вже
під кінець першого дня уже 70 чоловік
було на місці в тому числі декілька
виходили пішки з окупації з сум
коли я на говорить про те де вона бачила
цього депутата від слух народу а де вони
Софії фединої були тому вийде друзі про
готель Київ це готель де проживають
депутати які не мають житла в Києві і
саме там Яна ну жила до повномасштабного
вторгнення і її оця маленька кімнатка
вона там теж була таким певним штабом де
дійсно формувалися і пакувалися ось ці
правильні абсолютно рюкзаки взагалі Яна
та людина яка може чи не першою
поставила питання Що в рюкзаці має бути
в першу чергу правильний оцей джгут
правильно
турнікет фірми Сем така основна вещь
потому что честь всего К сожалению нашей
бойцы погибают тот массированого
кровотечение это спасает от массивный
кровотеча зараз по статистиці з тих всіх
поранених які ми вивозимо на 20% порвані
турнікети Я не розумію де вони їх беруть
можливо
волонтери може поставляють держава тобто
тут складно розібратися ми будемо
спробуємо розібратися всю державу і що
це таке і я буду про такі випадки
доповідать і на жаль всі поранені
знаходяться на полі бою зазвичай 5-7
годин і тому вони просто витікають і до
нас потрапляють уже мертвими і це дуже
велика втрата
серйозна тому що цій людині можна було
допомогти Бо в неї був просто якісний
турнікет Тим паче ця людина наклала тут
вона це змогла зробити і якби був
правильний вона б це тоже зробила і була
бджола
Тому це дуже велика біда нашого фронту
одна з таких найперших якщо говорити
Я вже не буду казати про
дефіцит кадрів про ще щось про те що на
посадах медиків у нас там інженери
там техніки і так далі Ну тобто люди які
поважають але при цьому
вони не професійні То вони не розуміють
їм дають медичну службу і кажуть керують
і що вони возиться на річці зробити ну
тобто це абсолютно абсурд
ну друзі
скажи скажи мені будь ласка От ти
все-таки дуже
зайнята людина і мала розповідаєш як на
мене несправедливо мало розповідає про
госпіталію от ці 550 людей своєї команди
скільки за час повномасштабного
вторгнення врятували тільки за час
повномасштабки ми врятували п'ять з
половиною тисяч людей Якщо говорити про
період до повномасштабки то ми врятували
ще 300 32 людей тобто загальна кількість
у нас велика вона вже скоро досягатиме
10 000 плюс до всього в мене є
реанімаційний автобус австрійка який має
можливість приймати там шість лежачих
поранених Які наприклад індубовані і при
цьому там приймати ще сидячих бійців і
ось зараз в нього там рекорд а він вивіз
уже 1000 людей тобто тільки один автобус
тільки один в нас Екіпаж скільки
госпіталірів працювали на найважчих
маріупольському у нас було декілька
позицій там Мар'їнка Авдіївка до яких ми
працювали на кожному було Екіпаж
переметів і коли повномасштабне
відбулося
наші не поїхали тому що одна з бійців
була пташка вона була на позиціях і вони
не могли її залишити на позицію вони її
чекали і відповідно поки чекали то вже
сталося оточення Маріуполя і відповідно
Вони всі прийшли полон
по
один білет у нас загинув двоє звільнених
і двоє ще досі був ув'язнення але по
одному Ми не маємо інформації де він
тільки по тільки по одному знаємо а
по-другому плюс до всього в нас
відбулася трагедія по
бійцю бізону тому що в нього була мати і
син
мати не опікували з дитиною в принципі і
відповідно
мати мається на увазі рідна хлопчи
і при цьому загинула На жаль від
інфаркта в один момент його мати тому
інша нашу бабуся хлопчика тому наша одна
полонена яка уже була звільнена стала
його опікуном і тепер живе з ним і чекає
коли звільнить старшого бізона ми всі
вболіваємо за долю безумовно Я знаю
скільки госпіталірів докладають зусиль
для того щоб настав той день коли ви
зможете вашій команді обійняти його і
він побачив сина звичайно Дай Боже щоб
всі наші полонені повернулися з полону
ти говориш про ну унікальні цифри 5,5
тисяч людей врятовано
важливо Це дуже вони довезені до
польових цих госпіталів до
стабілізаційних пунктів і далі вже
потрапили в руки лікарів в цих
госпіталях далі продовжується їх
лікування От скажи мені ви маєте
унікальний досвід все-таки такої ну
парадомоги і багато ти говориш про
джгути про ці от всі речі чую тебе
все-таки ці структури які мають чути чи
є з ними діалог що тут потрібно
активізація цих зусиль і це наша спільна
така і Парламентська має бути робота ну
принаймні вчора мені здалося що почули
коли я навела статистику що вона дійсно
20% поранених ідуть з розірваними Джими
то вони зацікавились цією темою і щиро
сказали що от пишіть за кожен випадок ми
будемо шукати звідки ті турнікети були
взяті ну тобто нібито найшло А але тема
ця стояла гостро ще не один рік
одночасно кажучи я сподіваюся звісно на
її вирішення цього року але тут треба
людям розуміти що не везлить дурниці
того що ви можете своїм турнікетом не
врятувати воїна А можете його вбити От і
все друзі дерева грати тільки
сертифіковані турнікети я розумію що
вони коштують 1500 грн там Січ і
Я це розумію ну лучше купить 20 хороших
чим 100 грн
тому що це розвіяться бійцям і вони на
них розраховуються їхні остання Надія
полібою Мені іноді навіть прикло що я не
Зінкевич так нечаста буває в телеефірі
рідко щось пише в соцмережах Але я
розумію чому Вона зайнята справжньою
справою вона його госпітальєри рятують
людей 550 госпітальєрів протягом півтора
року повномасштабного вторгнення
врятували більше п'яти тисяч військових
жінок і чоловіків і власне це величезна
робота яка заслуговує і дітей цивільних
дітей яких ви витягли з території які
були або під окупацією або під загрозою
окупації зазвичай від вони були
постраждалі від уламків і зелених
будинках Тобто ми відкопували
це люди які надають першу допомогу і
рятують і це викликає величезну повагу і
я ну для нас Велика радість і честь бути
в одній команді з тобою працювати над
багатьма речами що стосуються допомоги
кораненим
покращення тут законодавства але такої
спільної роботи дуже-дуже багато
попереду Мені здається що зараз такий
час
об'єднуватися тому що до перемоги що
далеко і працювати разом на цю перемогу
правда правильно